- [Instructor] When my father told me
that I was a bad driver,
I responded with only when
your sitting next to me.
All right, so let's think about this.
We have your underlined, so
what are we trying to say?
Only when your sitting next to me.
So it sounds okay, but
really when we're saying
your sitting next to me,
we're trying to say you're as short for
you are sitting next to me,
only when you are sitting next to me,
and that wouldn't be this your.
That would be the contraction
Y-O-U apostrophe R-E.
This is you are.
This is a contraction for you are,
so this is what we would want here.
We wouldn't want this.
They sound the same, that's your.
You pronounce this your as well.
Only when you're, you
are, sitting next to me.
We don't want Y-O-U-R.
Y-O-U-R, this is second
person referring to you,
but it's something you have, your,
so it's second-person possessive,
so this is a second-person possessive.
This is if we're talking
about something that you had
or I responded with if they're
talking to their father,
something that their father
only when, I don't know,
your watch is on or something.
It's indicating some type of possession,
so this is second-person
possessive right over here
which we do not want over there.
This is one of those mistakes
that I know I've done
even though I know it if
someone points it to me
or even if I look carefully, of course.
This is you are, while this is possessive,
but sometimes when you're
typing emails really fast,
this is a very easy mistake to do
because sometimes you
just type as things sound,
but this, we definitely
want to go with you are.
We want to go with you're,
the contraction for you are.